foreign
you may recall several months ago when
the White House announced one of its
newest hires determined to make his
administration resemble as closely as
possible in early 20th century freak
Show Biden decided to give a top level
job in the department of energy to A Man
Named Sam Britton Britain was named the
deputy assistant Secretary of the office
of spent Fuel and waste disposition and
was granted therefore one of the highest
security clearances in the department
this was interesting though not at all
surprising choice because Britain is a
bizarre cross-dressing creep who
identifies as a non-binary they them and
that's about the most normal thing about
him
so for your reference um here's a video
from just a couple of years ago when
Britain was an activist with the far
left group group The Trevor product
project and here he is explaining in
this video I believe it is the the
importance of pronouns
pronouns are
a
fascinating part of modern culture I
don't think many people think about them
very often until someone like myself or
others say their pronouns so when I
introduce myself I generally say hi my
name's Sam Britton I use they in them as
my pronouns and I serve as head of
advocacy and government Affairs for the
Trevor Project
I give this before I even give my job
because it's the important way that
you're going to describe me not what I
do but who I am
and that I respect for my gender is
really really important
foreign
of course you know everything he said
there is nonsense but
um he's dressed even more nonsensically
he looks like he got into a fight with a
Hot Topic mannequin and lost or maybe he
looks like a Jason Bourne cross-dressing
with a costume he bought on clearance at
Party City the day after Halloween worse
yet Britain is also a beastiality
fetishist who enjoys having sex with men
dressed like dogs and if you're
interested you can learn more about that
in one of the Kink 101 workshops that he
taught on college campuses and finally
to complete Britain's resume he also
wrote an article for the advocate in
2015 where he defended a website called
rent boy rent boy was it called which
had been shut down by the feds for
facilitating underage prostitution and
in the since deleted article Britain
worried that there would be serious
ramifications quote unquote to the gay
community if the prostitution site was
taken down he argued that rent boy was
performing a service by giving young
people a way to quote earn a living by
selling their bodies
so this guy is to summarize a sick
twisted deviant and for that reason not
in spite of it but because of it he was
made a high level official in the bite
Administration and that brings us to the
latest news first reported by a site
called alphanews.com
and here it is quote law enforcement at
the Minneapolis-St Paul International
Airport were alerted to a missing
suitcase in the baggage claim area on
September 16th the adult female victim
said she flew into MSP on a Delta flight
from New Orleans and went to retrieve
her check bag at Carousel Seven Airport
records confirmed the navy blue Vera
Bradley roller bag arrived at 4 40 PM
but was missing from the carousel so law
enforcement reviewed video surveillance
footage from the baggage claim area
and observed Britain removing a navy
blue roller bag from Carousel 7
according to a criminal complaint the
complaint says Britain removed a luggage
tag from the bag placed into a handbag
that he was carrying and then left the
area at a quick Pace brain arrived at
MSP airport around 2 4 27 on American
Airlines flight from Washington DC but
did not check a bag police showed the
surveillance video to the victim and she
confirmed it was her bag
now by the way just a side note here
take special note of the fact that he
didn't check a bag himself
which would negate any defense that he
took the bag by accident thinking that
you know was one of his own bags
there's no reason for him to even be in
the baggage claim area if he didn't
check a bag to begin with
unless he was there specifically to
steal a bag which appears to be the case
back to the article says Britain left
the airport in an Uber for a stay at the
Intercontinental Saint Paul Riverfront
Hotel where he checked in with the blue
bag the complaint says he returned to
MSP on September 18th with the bag in
hand for departing flight back to
Washington DC uh surveillance video from
Dulles International Airport shows
Britain traveling with the bag on
October 9th return trip from Europe the
victim said the estimated value of the
bag and its contents was around 2 325
dollars police questioned Britain about
the missing bag in an October 19th phone
call uh ninth phone call and asked him
directly if he took anything that did
not belong to him uh not that I know of
Britain allegedly responded he later
admitted to taking the bag but said the
clothes inside were his
I don't know how that would work
according to the complaint if I had
taken the wrong bag I'm happy to return
it but I don't have any clothes for
another individual uh that was my
clothes when I opened the bag he told
police
so someone else flying from a different
city had a bag that it magically had his
clothes in it Britain allegedly called
the investigating office two hours later
and apologized for not being completely
honest this time Britain said that he
took the bag because he was tired and
thought that it was his the complaint
says
he was tired sure that makes sense I
mean who hasn't been so tired while
traveling that they wander down to the
baggage claim bleary-eyed take a random
bag walk out with it take an Uber to the
hotel and then keep the bag and travel
with it again two weeks later
happens to the best of us
if it's possible his excuse only gets
worse from here because he later told
police that when he opened the bag in
his hotel room that he you know at that
point he noticed that it wasn't his but
he was nervous that they'd think that he
stole the bag so his solution was to
take all the clothes out and leave them
in the drawers in the hotel room but
take the bag with him
because he said it you thought it would
be weird to leave the bag with its
contents in the room
I suppose it's no surprise that this guy
doesn't have the clearest concept of
what is weird and what isn't
because if he did he'd realize that of
all the choices he could have made
throughout this ordeal he made each time
definitely the weirdest one
and that's if his story is even true
which of course it almost certainly
isn't uh police say that they never
recovered any clothes from his hotel
room uh by all appearances then he kept
not only the bag but he kept the
clothing as well and so he's now charged
with uh with a felony
Okay so
this whole Saga raises a question
it raises indeed more than one question
um and so a few of those questions are
things like you know why would this guy
brazenly steal a random woman's luggage
I mean didn't he realize there are
security cameras all over the airport
it's an airport
and it may have been a nice suitcase as
far suitcases go I don't know but was it
worth the criminal charge and public
embarrassment that we're sure to follow
you could not choose a worse place for
stealing luggage than an airport I don't
recommend stealing luggage at all but if
you're going to try it you're better off
trying to steal it from like the store
where it's sold than from an airport
where there are 15 cameras every Five
Paces
so what could possibly motivate this
sort of behavior
as to that last question I can only
speculate
but there is one answer that seems
pretty evident here it would seem that
Britain took the bag
because he has a cross-dressing fetish
and he gets off on the idea of wearing
some strange woman's clothing
why is he willing to put his career
reputation on the line well partly
because he knows he's in a protected
class and he can do whatever he wants
but also partly because deviant perverts
like Sam Britton are willing to risk
pretty much anything in pursuit of their
weird sick pleasures
they are driven almost exclusively by
their sexual desires this is true of any
fetishist who feels the need to live out
those fetishes in public
not only to live them out publicly but
to force the public to actively
participate in them
because this is what modern tolerance is
so often about it's about allowing
people usually men to involve the whole
world in their sexual fetishes
many of The Men Who call themselves
trans are really just Auto gynophiles
and many of them who call themselves
non-binary are really just
cross-dressing fetishes it's as simple
as that
and we have elevated The Fetish to a
lifestyle that we all not only have to
tolerate
which we shouldn't even have to do that
but but also uh uh uh
affirm it
which is to participate in it we have
empowered these troubled people in our
society rather than encouraging them to
seek psychological treatment and
spiritual healing for their perverse and
unnatural desires which is what they
need
and when you Empower that enough you end
up and you Empower it to the level that
Sam Britton has been literally empowered
by being given a position in the White
House you end up with exactly what
happened at the Minneapolis Airport and
that is why Sam Britton is most
certainly and I imagine probably not for
the first time in this show canceled and
I'll do it for this portion of the show
as you move over to members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]